welcome to deconstructing chatbots I am
Priyanka Rock area and in this episode
we are going to build our first chat bot
[Music]
like a promise we are going to jump
right into the dialogue flow interface
navigate to consult or dialogue flow
calm and fine in if you're a first-time
user then just use your email to sign up
accept all the terms and conditions and
you'll be in the console now create new
agent let's call this appointment
scheduler dialogue flow creates a GCP
project for you to access logs and cloud
functions you can select an existing
project as well then just create you get
to default intents as a part of your
agent the default welcome intent helps
greet your users and the default
fallback intent helps catch all the
questions that your bot does not
understand at this point you have a
functional bot all it does is greet the
users well let's test it if we say hi
our bar responds back with a hi and how
I can help message once you ask for help
such as set an appointment it does not
know what to do so it kicks in the
fallback intent obviously because we've
not created any intern to catch that
particular request so it's not bad now
let's create a new intent and call it
scheduled appointment we will skip
context and events for now let's get
down to the training phrases and add
some phrases here as you're putting
these in you will see date and time are
automatically identified a system entity
date and time now to make this
functional we need to respond back to
the user so let's add a response you
could just say you're all set
see you then or you could make it a
little bit more interesting and say
you're all set for this date and this
time see you then
the dollar sign here helps you access
the entity values that's just it
set an appointment for 4 p.m. on
Thursday and as expected you get the
right response with the right date and
time now what if somebody just said set
an appointment well that is not very
specific and we have not yet handled
that scenario in our body to support
this we use something called slot
filling we make the entities as required
and dialogue flow we'll make sure to ask
for both date and time before it
responds back let's add what time would
you like to come in for the time prompt
and what date for the date prompt you
can add other variants too and then just
save ok let's test one more time to see
if things are working let's say set an
appointment our bot responds with what
time would you like to come in and I say
10 a.m. and then it asks for the date
and I say February 12th all right got
all that it's all working okay so all
the testing we did so far has been in
the simulator but what if you wanted to
share this win with a friend let's go
into integration and enable the verb
demo and just like that you have a link
to your bot that you can share or iframe
into your website or a mobile
application you can test to see if it's
working
all right so today we set up a simple
appointment scheduler that takes date
and time as input variables and responds
back to the user with an appointment
confirmation we also learned about stop
filling if a user only provided us with
the date or time or nothing how you can
prompt the user to provide the missing
information seamlessly and finally we
learn how to test our bot in the
simulator and integrated it into a
website don't miss the next episode of
deconstructing chat BOTS because we are
going to make our appointment scheduler
a little bit smarter
[Music]